DON'T WANT TO HAVE A MASSIVE
INTERCONTINENTAL NUKE FEST.
THE SHAM REFERENDUMS THAT ENDED
TONIGHT IN RUSSIAN-OCCUPIED
REGIONS OF UKRAINE SHOW THAT
HUGE MAJORITIES SUPPORT JOINING
RUSSIA.
SHOCKER.
AND UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ARE
SAYING THIS IS A WAY FOR RUSSIA
TO DRAFT UKRAINIAN MEN INTO THE
MILITARY TO BE USED AS CANNON
FODDER.
I DO WANT TO WARN YOU THAT WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IS
DISTURBING, BUT, WE FEEL,
IMPORTANT.
>> THE BODIES OF DEAD RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS ARE SCATTERED AROUND
THIS TOWN, KILLED FAR FROM HOME
IN WHAT THE KREMLIN CHOOSES TO
CALL A SPECIAL MILITARY
OPERATION.
BUT IT'S A WAR BY ANY OTHER
NAME.
A WAR INTO WHICH MANY MORE
RUSSIANS WILL BE THROWN NOW THAT
THE SO-CALLED PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION HAS BEGUN.
AND WHO MAY WELL MEET A SIMILAR
END.
>> THIS IS A BANK DOCUMENT FOUND
ON ONE OF THE SOLDIERS.
THE SOLDIER IS FROM ST.
PETERSBURG, AND HE WAS BORN ON
THE 30th OF SEPTEMBER, 2001.
HE DIED THREE DAYS BEFORE HIS
BIRTHDAY.
>> Reporter: THE CHARRED
REMNANTS OF RUSSIAN ARMOR
SCATTERED AROUND TOWN.
OUTGOING ARTILLERY ONCE
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL ON EARTH.
AN ARMY THAT ABANDONED TANKS
APLENTY, MANY IN WORKING ORDER.
DMITRI AND HIS CREW ARE
TINKERING WITH ONE SUCH TANK
FRESH FROM THE BATTLEFIELD.
>> Translator: IT HAS MINIMAL
BREAKAGE.
I CAN TURN IT ON NOW WITHOUT ANY
PROBLEMS.
>> Reporter: SURE ENOUGH, ITS
MOTOR ROARS TO LIFE.
>> Translator: WHEN THEY RUN
AWAY, THEY LOSE NOT ONLY THE
TANKS, BUT ALSO THE AMMUNITION,
AND THE NEXT DAY IT'S ALL USED
AGAINST THEM.
>> Reporter: THIS TANK ALMOST
READY TO GO BACK INTO ACTION.
THIS CITY LIES JUST NORTH OF THE
DONBAS REGION, WHICH AFTER SHAM
REFERENDUM PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN PLANS TO ANNEX TO RUSSIA.
YET, FEW HERE HAVE FOND MEMORIES
OF LIFE UNDER RUSSIA'S SWAY.
THIS PERSON IS CUTTING SHEET
METAL TO PUT OVER THE SHATTERED
WINDOWS OF HIS SISTER'S HOME.
>> Translator: THERE WAS LOOTING
IN SPRING.
THEY WERE TAKING EVERYTHING.
>> Reporter: DOWN THE ROAD, THEY
ARE BACK TO WHAT THEY DID
THROUGHOUT THE RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION.
>> Translator: JUST SITTING
HERE.
THEY DIDN'T BOTHER US.
>> Reporter: BUT SHE FOUND THEM
ANNOYING.
>> Translator: NAZIS, NAZIS, SHE
SAYS.
THEY ALWAYS ASK, WHERE ARE THE
NAZIS.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIANS HAVE
LEFT OR LIE DEAD IN THE DIRT.
LIVES WASTED FOR NOTHING.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO IMAGINE
WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO SEE THAT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT BOY, I MEAN,
19 OR 20 YEARS OLD WITH THE BANK
DOCUMENT.
AND, FOR YOU, WHAT IS IT LIKE AS
YOU HAVE COVERED SO MUCH OF THIS
WAR TO WALK THROUGH A TOWN LIKE
THAT AND SEE DEAD BODIES OF
RUSSIAN BOYS ALL OVER THE PLACE?
>> Reporter: I MEAN, IT WAS JUST
SHOCKING THE NUMBER OF DEAD
RUSSIANS WE SAW.
WE COUNTED AT LEAST 22 BODIES.
AND WE WERE REALLY IN THAT TOWN
ONLY ABOUT 50 MINUTES TO AN
HOUR.
AND WE REALLY DIDN'T EVEN GET A
COMPLETE LOOK AT THE SITUATION
THERE.
BUT JUST TO ADD SOME MORE NEWS
FOR YOU, THIS CITY KHARKIV WHERE
WE ARE NOW JUST ABOUT FIVE HOURS
AGO CAME UNDER RUSSIAN, RATHER,
MISSILE FIRE ABOUT FIVE MISSILES
LANDED, ONE OF THEM JUST ABOUT
600 YARDS FROM WHERE WE ARE NOW.
IT TOOK AN ELECTRONIC SUBSTATION
OUT.
AND THE CITY, MUCH OF THE CITY
IS COMPLETELY WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY.
IN FACT, I CAN SEE JUST A COUPLE
LIGHTS IN THE BACKGROUND,
PERHAPS THOSE ARE FROM
GENERATORS.
BUT THIS JUST GIVES YOU AN IDEA
THAT DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE LOSING GROUND IN
THIS PART OF UKRAINE, THEY STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY WITH THEIR
LONG-RANGE MISSILES TO CAUSE
SERIOUS DAMAGE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SOLIDIFY
WHATEVER CONTROL THEY HAVE OVER
CERTAIN OCCUPIED AREAS THAT THEY
ARE STILL TRYING TO ATTACK
KHARKIV.
BEN WEDEMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT POWERFUL REPORT.
I WANT TO GO TO RETIRED ARMY
MAJOR GENERAL JAMES SPIDER
MARKS.
GENERAL, WHAT'S YOUR REACTION
WHEN YOU SEE THAT?
OBVIOUSLY THAT TOWN THAT BEN
SPENT LESS THAN AN HOUR AND IS
EXTREMELY CLOSE TO THE LINE THAT
PUTIN IS NOW GOING TO DEFINE AS
THE LINE OF RUSSIA.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S GOING TO TRY TO
SAY, AND THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
NOW AND THERE'S LITERALLY JUST,
AS THE RUSSIANS RETREATED, THEY
CERTAINLY DID NOT TAKE THEIR
DEAD.
IT SEEMS TO BE LITTERED WITH
RUSSIAN BODIES.
AND BEN WASN'T EVEN COUNTING,
BUT AT LEAST 22 THAT HE SAW JUST
LYING THERE.
>> WHAT THIS REALLY TELLS YOU IS
WHAT WE'VE SEEN THE RUSSIANS
DOING FOR THE PAST SEVEN MONTHS.
LOOK, THERE'S NO HUMANITY IN
THIS FIGHT.
THERE'S NO SENSE OF LEADERSHIP,
AS WE'VE DESCRIBED.
THERE'S AN ABSENCE IN TERMS OF
ANY TYPE OF A PROFESSIONAL
ETHOS.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
RESISTANCE.
AND WE'RE SEEING THE PICTURES OF
THE RESISTANCE TO THIS
MOBILIZATION THAT PRESIDENT
PUTIN'S PUT IN PLACE.
BECAUSE IT'S OBVIOUS WHAT CAN
POSSIBLY HAPPEN.
THEY'RE GOING TO A FIGHT WHERE
THE RUSSIAN SOLDIER IS ONLY
FIGHTING FOR A PAYCHECK AND
ESSENTIALLY A BUCKET OF LIES,
AND THE UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING
FOR THEIR SOVEREIGNTY.
>> AND THE IMAGES WE'VE SEEN ARE
STUNNING.
YOU CAN SEE THEM FROM SPACE,
SATELLITE IMAGES OF
TEN-MILE-LONG LINES AT THE
BORDER.
THE EXPECTATION NOW THAT THOSE
BORDERS COULD BE FORCIBLY
CLOSED.
SORT OF A PANIC OF MEN TRYING TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
AND YOU'VE SEEN CRITICISM FROM
QUARTERS THAT WE'VE NOT EVER
SEEN CRITICISM.
THAT'S THE SATELLITE LINE ON THE
RUSSIAN/GEORGIAN BORDER THAT WE
HAVE ON THE SCREEN.
ONE RUSSIAN TELEVISION ANCHOR,
WHO HAS BEEN ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROPONENTS OF PUTIN ACTUALLY
CRITICIZED IN A BIZARRE WAY.
LET ME PLAY IT.
>> Translator: THE IDIOTS OUT
THERE WHO ARE CALLING UP
MUSICIANS OR INDIVIDUALS WITH A
MILLION ILLNESSES OR STUDENTS,
DESPITE THE CLEARLY DEFINED
EXEMPTIONS LAID OUT IN THE
DECREE.
NOT ONLY SHOULD THEY BE
PUNISHED, BUT THEY SHOULD BE THE
FIRST TO BE SENT TO THE FRONT
LINES.
IF ANYONE WISHES TO DISCREDIT
OUR SUPREME COMMANDER IN CHIEF,
I'D STRONGLY ADVISE AGAINST IT.
>> SO HE CRITICIZES AND OF
COURSE ULTIMATELY THE ONLY BLAME
FOR ANY OF THAT WOULD BE ON THE
ULTIMATE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
BUT SAYS, OH, I'M NOT DOING
THAT.
BUT IT IS RARE NONETHELESS TO
HEAR THAT, AND CERTAINLY FROM
HIM, AS I SAID, A PERSON WHO HAS
BEEN A BIG PROPONENT OF ALL
SORTS OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THAT, IF AT
ALL?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S
SIGNIFICANT IN THAT WHAT HE IS
SAYING IS THE EXECUTION OF THIS
MOBILIZATION.
HOW THEY'RE GOING ABOUT IT.
IT IS COMPLETELY FULL OF HOLES.
IT'S NOT BEING DONE VERY WELL AT
ALL.
IT'S APPARENT THAT THERE ISN'T A
SENSE OF WHAT THE TOP-LINE
POLICY IS AND HOW THAT CASCADES
THROUGH THE VARIOUS REGIONS AND
HOW IT NEEDS TO BE EXECUTED.
BUT WHAT HE IS DOING IS HE'S
SAYING, LOOK, EVERYBODY OUT
THERE IS A FOOL EXCEPT FOR
PUTIN.
SO DON'T FORGET THAT.
PUTIN'S IN CHARGE, HE KNOWS WHAT
HE'S DOING, WE'RE SURROUNDED BY
A BUNCH OF DUMMIES.
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
RESULT UNLESS WE GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER.
>> WHAT ABOUT MEDVEDEV SAID
TODAY, WHICH IS NATO, EUROPE,
THE U.S. WON'T DO ANYTHING IF
RUSSIA USES NUKES IN UKRAINE.
AND THEY WON'T DO ANYTHING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
A BIG INTERNATIONAL NUCLEAR WAR
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WOULD DIE.
SO BASICALLY WE CAN USE NUKES IN
UKRAINE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S TRUE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S TRUE AT
ALL.
THE FACT IS THE BENEFIT, THE
REAL STRATEGIC VALUE OF NUKES IS
IN THEIR DETERRENT EFFECT.
WHEN YOU USE A NUKE, YOU'VE LOST
ITS EFFECTIVE VALUE.
AND I WOULD TELL YOU THAT IF A
NUKE WAS USED, AND I CAN'T GET
INTO DESCRIPTIONS OF WHETHER
IT'S TACTICAL OR YIELD,
SHORT-RANGE, OR IF IT'S A
SPECIFIC UKRAINIAN TARGET OR IF
THEY DO IT OVER THE ARCTIC POLE
SOMEPLACE AS A DEMONSTRATION.
I WOULD GUARANTEE IF THAT TOOK
PLACE, THERE WOULD BE A U.S.-LED
COALITION INSERT